[Music]
can you tell a story about a specific
instance
a teaching moment that you recall while
being at the office
oh god um yeah this is a this is a real
how much time you got kind of a deal
because i could tell you a thousand i
got as much time as you'd like
okay so i'll answer both of the
questions which are different the day
one stuff the phd level class
day one in the same way that a professor
of newtonian physics would say
would write f equals ma on the board and
then everyone would scribble it down in
there
in their notebooks or type i guess and
this is how it's showing you how old i
am that i'm still imagining people
taking notes with a pen i still scribble
there you go
so the f equals m.a of sitcom writing is
stuff like okay here's what matters in
stories right what matters is
characters motivations for doing what
they do
the plots having good twists and turns
in them because comedy is all about
thwarting expectation and if people see
something coming then they'll they won't
laugh
being surprising
escalation is another big one right if
if you see a story where the same thing
happens two scenes in a row you get
bored so whatever happens in the second
scene has to be bigger and more intense
than what happened in the first one
there are certain things that i think
you would establish as f equals m a type
rules that you would then
undermine right like you would say
there's a there's a certain quality that
executives like to refer to as
likability
which is a kind of a reductive term but
it essentially means that if people if
audiences don't in some way identify
with characters they don't like those
characters and
that doesn't mean in the world we're in
now and this has been true probably
since roughly speaking the sopranos came
on board and suddenly the main character
of the biggest show on tv was a
sociopathic mobster who killed people
regularly
you wouldn't call it strictly speaking
likability but you might call it
relatability you might say the main
characters on a show or have to have
some aspect of them that people can see
in themselves or at least identify with
or say i have a cousin who's like that
or something like that those are the
amino acids right that's like the basic
folding blocks of life yeah as far as
teaching moments
as many aphorisms as lauren michael's
had about
comedy greg has just as many
and i'll give you one example so i wrote
an episode of the office in the second
season that was about it was a christmas
episode and it was an episode where they
were doing us a secret santa so they'd
each draw on a name and they had you
know this person is buying a little gift
for this person and this person is
buying a little gift for this person or
whatever
and the premise which was really funny
was that michael didn't like his gift
right so michael's gift came from a
character named phyllis on the show and
she had knitted him some oven mitts and
he just didn't like them he didn't think
they were a big enough gift and he and
he had gotten
he had drawn ryan ryan was the temp
played by bj novak he had drawn ryan in
the
secret santa gift exchange draw
and he had bought ryan a video ipod
so even though it's a classic michael
scott thing because there was a 25 limit
or whatever and he because he was so
desperate to be loved just bought this
kid a 400 video ipod so he gave a video
ipod to his person and then he got for
his gift a woven of admit and just lost
his mind and so he changed it
from a secret santa to a yankee swap
which is where you can swap your gift
for any of the other gifts it's another
gift right because he wanted to unload
the oven mitts and get something better
so
when i wrote the episode i did this
thing where i i was like okay well the
reality i've been a part of many secret
santas in many offices and i i know how
you do it you do a draw so i put all the
characters names into a hat and i did a
real draw i said like okay oscar is
drawing now and i picked out and it was
creed okay oscar's gonna buy a grip for
crete so i did it the way it would
really be done and
there was a one of the characters had
angela angelo was a character on the
show who
was very uptight and fairly religious
and
she
was very prim she didn't like to
curse she didn't do anything that was
sort of like she was just very very
uptight
and so i had in the script that someone
bought for her
a sort of
vaguely christian kind of self-help book
that was sort of like you know it was
like seven habits for following in the
light of god or something like that it
was just like a sort of one of those one
of those books that are perfectly lovely
and helpful for people who are looking
for some guidance in their lives and who
are religious
and it didn't factor into the plot at
all it was just a detail of the script
that that's what she got
and greg was like
no we should come up with something else
and i was kind of confused because i was
like it's not even a joke we don't even
make a joke about it it's just literally
like she opens the gift and
and then that's what it is
but he was like yeah here's the thing
though we already know that angela is
religious and we already know that she
is the kind of person who would buy a
book like that or who would like a book
like that
and what would be better is if there was
something that were like
overlapping in the overlapping area of
the venn diagram of what we already know
about her
and what we can learn about her that
would broaden her
character right that would make her into
a more interesting person dimensionalize
her a little bit
and so what we came up with was
that she loved
those kind of photographs that people
take where they where babies are dressed
like adults you know that you know
there's like a weird corner of the
photography world where it's like a baby
but dressed like a jazz musician with
like a
like a fedora and like a toy saxophone
and somehow i don't know why but somehow
that was like that's perfect like that
is exactly the kind of thing that she
would like may i interrupt for a second
yeah how the hell does that come out of
the ether did it just pop into someone's
head i mean how did it land there i can
tell you definitively that i did not
pitch it because i believe i was
completely unaware of this phenomenon
but that's why you have a room full of
funny people because you just say okay
here's the character here's the subject
matter
pitch on what she would like pitch on
some aspect of the culture and some i
wish i remember too someone pitched that
and immediately was like oh my god
that's perfe i don't know why but that's
perfect so
so we changed it to someone got her this
poster of two babies dressed like jazz
musicians
and
again it didn't factor into the episode
in any meaningful way but that poster
was then added to the set she put it up
next to her later in the season
we designed an entire episode over the
fact that another person who sat near
her hated it so much that there was like
an hr complaint lodged against her
and
and it like it flowered it just bloomed
into this thing that
lasted for
years and years and years and so
greg's thing and this is what that
vanity fair article is referencing was
like at the end of every episode of the
show you should have at least a little
bit more information about some of the
characters than you did before the
episode started and it doesn't have to
be a huge thing it doesn't have to be
like my dad was you know arrested as a
serial murderer or something it doesn't
have to be some gigantic thing it just
has to be a little bit more than what
you knew before and as long as that's
the case the show continues to be more
interesting and kind of grow and expand
you